on me lance et par le monde de la
restauration
la situation est d'ores et déjà
catastrophique pour certains
responsables d'établissements pour les
aider certains maires ont déjà annoncé
qu'il supprimerait la taxe terrasse une
vraie müller dont va bénéficier ceux
captés chalonnais bien sûr c'est très
intéressant
cette mesure est une avancée réelle mais
selon le syndicat hôtelier lui a mis h
elle n'est pas suffisante de nombreux
restaurateurs pourrait ne pas avoir la
trésorerie nécessaire pour ouvrir une
fois la crise passée avant d'avoir reçu
leur avancement
les salariés que ça ça va déjà très
difficile moi j'ai alerté fasse en sorte
soutiennent nos entreprises
[Musique]
en fait la sourde oreille il faut faire
des formats en plus finir et
malheureusement cette situation risque
de perdurer
déjà les vacances de pâques qui marque
habituellement le début de la belle
saison sont à oublier